[Musique]
mes petits amis
nous venons vous dire au revoir car ce
soir nous ramenons rémi toto et fanfan
chez leur maman jeter sans les chercher
patron je veux embrasser nikolov up
dépêche-toi nounours je t'attends bon le
chemin aux boeufs pour propos mais je
vous promets que nous reviendrons très
bientôt vous voir enfin claqué passage
je te confie cette valise elle est
pleine des sandwichs et de bon vivre au
miel on peut au très bon soir du petit
ami et b2 alors vous êtes prêts pour ce
voyage ils sont tous prêts c'est une
petite valise pour fait est que ce
gentil ge tient un quart des biscuits on
merci nicolas anot auto c'est pour le
voyage allons mes petits neveux dit au
revoir à pimprenelle et nicolas ont
atteint 90
juste une petite photo avant que vous
portiez tient la mettrais devenez flers
non pas une seconde les enfants
ce n'est pas mon bon là haut est tendue
je prends ni de leur ca parfait ne bouge
plus
ça y est maintenant david lynch et howie
à toute la famille nos nouveaux nés mes
neveux là ne touchent pas frappant toto
ne fait pas de tous les matches c'est un
beau sourire et me tais toi aussi
maintenant on sort et attention 2 3
c'est comme ça on aura votera photos
pendant que vous êtes en voyage
vous m'en garderais une pour mettre tant
macherot cette rame y allons en avons
rémi toto et fanfan au revoir les
enfants à bien tous oui il va vous
chanter sa chanson tous au revoir les
enfants pour voir tous nos amis
à bientôt je suis le marchand de stable
la journée
et fini il faut être raisonnable
c'est le moment d'aller au lit tous les
jours sur mon nuage
[Musique]
nous nous revient avec moi et nous
partons en voyage dans le ciel par
dessus les toits
[Musique]
en
je n'ai pas d'autre bagages qu'un niveau
enchanté et du haut de mon nuage je
serai memon stable doré on soir les
enfants du monde
à demain
une nuit moi je continue ma ronde
bonne nuit à tous les petits os ne nuit
à tous les tirs
bordeaux nuit tous feux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]